all right everyone's looking really good
today
are you sure
is this your dream scenario right now
well not if I'm all okay the fly is
attracted to me it's finally something
sexual
I'm a fly that's Miami I so badly want
to just have my crotch on her head while
you're getting banged out
slugs we have the biggest announcement
of Our Lives pinch yourselves pinch
yourself you ain't dreaming
we are finally here today to tell you
that on September 12th the day after you
oh Annie that's not relevance
you can finally get trash Tuesday merch
and it's so cute
cute cool awesome designs each of these
are available just click the link below
we have look kalila and are modeling
them in extra larges that we're wearing
as dresses I'm wearing a small tank top
and it's my favorite tank top I've ever
owned I love it so much it's so cute I
wore it on stage last night everybody
loved it
um we're so excited about our new merch
we're going to be wearing it 24 7
because we can't believe it took us two
years to get here these are so comfy so
cute cut them crop them
and then go out in the world and meet
other slugs and talk about skull you
know what to do
where us hey sluggies Welcome to our new
set we're so excited so many fun things
coming I am on the road as always I'll
be at the comedy store for the next
Annie wood and Friends September 20th
get your tickets it always sells out
I'll be in Austin Texas at the Vulcan
October 6th and 7th I'm going to be in
La Jolla shooting my comedy special
October 13th and 14th I'll be in San
Jose California at The Improv November
17th and 18th and Houston Texas December
15th and 16th I am always adding dates
so go to annieleterman.com shows for
tickets
hi I'm Esther and I'm a stand-up
comedian and my tour is back on and next
week September 28th I'm going to be in
Washington DC and you better get your
tickets because the first show it
already sold out still tickets for the
second show at the DC Improv and then
and then where
Boston September 30th at the Wilbur you
can get tickets at
estheronice.com I'm bringing a special
guest who's never been with me uh on my
tour before
and then I'll be in Chicago San Diego
all these great places get tickets at
astronice.com I love you this show is
sponsored by betterhelp get a break from
your thoughts with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com trash Tuesday
thank you to our sponsor quip if you if
you go to get quip.com if you go to
getquip.com trash Tuesday right now you
get 20 off any electric toothbrush mint
and gum dispenser water flosser that's
20 off any electric toothbrush mint in
gum dispenser water flosser at
getquip.com trash Tuesday spelled
g-e-t-quip.com trash Tuesday quip the
good habits
so today is the handmaid's Tale theme as
you can tell a Little Red Riding Hood
we're a little late this is showing
about eight years ago but it's never
Annie just started watching so I have no
clue what's happening I don't know how
to even talk about it wait what season
are you on I three or four I don't know
it just this happens to me every time I
try to watch it I start watching it I my
80d drifts off I come back I go what's
going on so are we gonna have like a
like a Game of Thrones themed one like
anything no we can't I've never seen
that that's what I'm saying when you
finally catch up yeah I don't I don't
know if I can she's not for Game of
Thrones I don't like it's violent
mythical things like real like women
being held down like real life you like
real murder who would you who would you
have been
um in handmaid's world
I probably would have been someone that
followed the rules Serena Joy oh you
yeah you would have been the one
you think I had any chance of being
Serena Joy you would have been you would
be her you're blonde no no no you would
be the chick that got ended up getting
the gun and then she got shot to death
they thank you why I remember that they
followed all the rules ratted everyone
out got everyone in trouble and then
eventually snapped no I want to work
what's that place where all the like
sexy stuff that's where I want to be too
that place seems fun we're the commander
and his friends go to yeah yeah it's
definitely better than the Annie is the
one who smoked steak she got her eye
gouged out because she um tried to steal
her baby back that's off Warren right I
try to catch yeah I try to catch the
stream she's the prettiest one
so that's nice that you are get to be
the pretty one when are you gonna just
admit that it was me wanted to get
tattooed on your arm
when's the
but don't you think that's only fair to
get Annie on the other side I I think if
I get another tattoo that it will be the
end of me and Dave like he's he also
recently pointed out that all I have are
words and like that that's kind of a
weird ugly thing like there's no
actual it's just sloppy words well what
would you get an apple what did you get
to represent Eve Adam and Eve no get a
rib you are a little red
wait are mcrib's gone again
they're look McDonald's has been playing
tricks on us for a long time they come
they go I can't keep it's like skims
they're always sold out so they just do
drops then right they do draw yeah
um well
I recently did see a tick tock of some
guy reviewing the phileo fish and he was
like this is actually really high
quality Cod and like the filet fish is
like a really healthy option wait I love
I love fly fish I do too it's my
favorite I don't like the tartar sauce
it's so good it is can we bring up the
nutritional value of cod because it just
seems like a tilapia kind of fish to me
I know but then you think about like all
the best Japanese restaurants like is it
maybe uh what's Nobu they're a famous
thing is like a miso Cod well have you
been there you were just Googling it on
Yelp I've never go on my Google Maps and
pretend you're going in
going a little virtual date with
yourself and I put like filters on and
give myself a top and they let you in
they go oh it's you
wait I was killed oh wow I was really
anti-metaverse in the beginning but
you're kind of giving it a good spin
Todd and I went to Japan together in the
metaverse we went we just went on Google
Maps and walked around the streets
that's the hottest story it's a sweet
date wait a second is there do they have
any of the
um Omega fatty acids and cod because you
know tilapia doesn't it doesn't I didn't
know that the tilapia is like I don't
know why I'm really sad that my people
love it but it's it's like a trash fish
wait speaking of your people yes do you
know who Eva noblesada is oh my God yeah
I've been following her forever she is
how did you know about her because she
is a Broadway star Lea Salonga was a
Filipino Broadway star okay you know
they all know they like follow they are
fans of each other I know a few months
ago you said like no one can entertain
like Filipinos but you were right
she had a show at Joe's Pub after mine
and I stayed and watched her and I saw
her in a Hades Town yeah she's half
Filipina half Mexican
so if you and Carlos ever did consummate
any time now you could make one of her
um but she's like I've been literally
obsessively watching videos of her
singing and I'm
I'm in love like I love her and her
boyfriend is really talented
um what's his name Carney yeah what is
he he is also a star is he Filipino no
he's just so he's just a boring white
guy but no I know she is out of this
world talented it's like I am I want her
to be my mommy can you pull up a picture
of her can I see what she looks like can
you ask her to be my mommy I can try I
think she was in a movie called yellow
rose okay as well okay
um you're so lucky you're short so you
can play this little baby game when I
met her because I met her at Joe's 25
year old begging someone younger than
her no she's like 27.
this is so cute sometimes when I do meet
a Filipino person I kind of always want
to be like hey
you do have a lot of Filipino friends
isn't Shea Filipina yeah yeah no I know
but you know does she acknowledge being
friends with you
here's what I'll say have you been
photographed together celebrities don't
always text back and I think that's
healthy how many texts do you send
before you're like all right I try to
you know change it up maybe a text here
and then maybe switch it to a DM do you
wait for like a birthday or is it just
oh a birthday no it's so like hey do you
wanna you know when you were um filming
did it feel like you guys were genuinely
friends and then it's sort of just like
this is the thing with all like any show
that I've my experience it's like we
like especially on doll face that
foursome we became literal best friends
like for the whole time we were filming
and I guess like maybe it's kind of like
you know when you're at a party and
everyone's drunk except for me and then
like the next morning no one remembers
but me like I was like kind of thought
it would just like keep going but well
or it's like you know when you work at a
restaurant and like those are your best
friend you know you you're with them all
the time and then when you leave that
job you never talk to them again it's
the same thing but they're all like
invited parties you're not invited to so
they continue on it's like summer camp
it's exactly that and I would totally if
I had been
um
you know mature enough to go to a
Sleepaway Camp and not cry I need to be
picked up I'm sure that I would have
formed an like a bigger bond with
everyone and then would have like held
on too tight wait what is sleep away
camp
like my Camp was you could go two weeks
or did you go to sleep away camp yeah
Quaker camp for how long
I went from when I was nine years old to
14. did you hurt anybody
no
I didn't hurt anyone
I got pissed though because they had a
they had this thing called the Pioneer
and they would pick the counselor to
basically pick their favorite campers
and then they would take them the
Pioneer was like a canoeing and camping
trip so they would take you you would go
canoe and hike for four days or
something and they could only take like
10 people and I remember getting really
mad that they didn't pick the unpopular
girls from the like it was their last
year and they picked like popular girls
from my tent and not like that had
another year to go I remember I was
always like the social justice Warrior
sweet I also stole all the candy I got
um I learned how to pick a law because I
was getting to juvenile delinquent age
okay so you did it was like I was like
Quaker Camp there was one over lapia
where I was like a young criminal and
still a Quaker child and so I went to
Quaker camp and I took a bobby pin and I
found we weren't allowed to bring can't
have candy on our own because of wild
animals coming into the bunks when we're
sleeping
so you could have they had like candy
night once every two weeks and so I
found the safe with all the candy and I
picked it with a bobby pin and I stole
the candy and I like Robin hooded it out
that is cute that you were a Quaker
criminal I was a Quaker criminal I once
like for with my dance studio we went to
um like a dude ranch where like a
sleepover weekend and obviously moms
came that's why I was able to handle it
and everyone was going horseback riding
but there was one girl this girl I think
her name was Kayla Mathis she was like
such a good dancer and she had really
severe asthma so she couldn't do the
horseback riding and I was like
guys I'll stay with her I'm gonna stay
back with Kayla it's all good I have to
study her and see how to fake asthma
this is going to come in handy in my
future I was like I'll keep her company
don't worry but it's just obviously so
scared and didn't want to get on a horse
you want a horse is the funniest thing I
could possibly do have you ever ridden a
horse Esther
I don't think so
scary pony
her little legs would be dangling they
wouldn't a little Shetland
wait speaking of pony donut
donut
okay she's
sorry donut is here today and she's
camera shy is there I know
um the handmaid's tale is basically a
nightmare right like everything
about it feels nightmarish but is there
any upside at all
to
um living in a society
like that for us is there any is there
any while you're watching the show
you're like
that part I have an upside uh the women
aren't allowed to read
I'm like that would be all let's just
take it off the table
playing field baby
you know
the grocery stores looked really clean
and organized and people had to be kind
of your friend and walk next to you yeah
you had to have a friend your friend or
the fact that you were around a lot of
girls all the time that seems fun that
seems a little bit but you had a whisper
I would not survive
I'm not much of a Whisperer you know I
don't take rules well I'd be killed I
would have been hearing what you said I
would have been hanging from the wall
pretty quick but you're very fertile so
you would have been useful they would
have been banging me out left and right
I would have been banged the out
you would have been one of the wives
Serena Joy yeah you do have Serena Joy
energy you know what I'll take that
you'd be really maybe some kind of a
right so I'd low-key just be like
jerking off well
what was happening it is true though
that the sorry that going to the club
was like so like the club girls had the
best life
they were like drinking and smoking and
wearing like Flappers dresses yeah I
mean they were violently every night but
it would there was a fun Side
by different guys it wasn't the same guy
all the time at least and if they were
high and drunk like you know wait were
they allowed to be drugged out
I think I think so I'll tell you what I
the worst role is a market I cannot cook
and clean for free and the markets
aren't right well I mean they're
actually that's not the worst rule I
think any any rule where someone's being
raped I think is the worst sure I mean
worse I think than having to cook
shoulders and
I would have been an absolute I would
have been a Martha for sure okay but
also think about this about being a
handmaid like you and I have both been
pregnant before for eight weeks and it's
really hard like to go through that for
someone else is that's horrifying
don't you think yeah and we'll get ready
because you will be surrogating mine
I'm placing I'm placing two in each of
you
I'm gonna give you the happy if you
would like be so mean to me on the
inside
oh my god oh sweet did you know that if
you get preg the person who gets you
pregnant you like get their DNA in you
forever and it can like change your this
girl was like after he got me pregnant
my hair became curly like his yeah so
the uh DNA fragments enter the
bloodstream you and Dave are gonna have
to be like using the CPAP like
no but it's not always a positive
so what she
what cheating was it's either a negative
a neutral no effect or a positive effect
so for instance like that girl I think I
think we might have watched the same
time yeah
um she was explaining how like she
suffers from a lot of like autoimmune
stuff and her husband does not like he's
just very hearty like biologically Hardy
and so when she's when she got pregnant
with this baby she started to kind of
feel like um her autoimmune disease was
in remission a lot and she started to
feel like oh whoa like I wonder why that
is but I think that's common with
pregnancy yes like because my friend who
has Ms told me that when you're pregnant
she's like I I don't even need to be on
my Ms drugs because my body like takes
care like your Ms almost goes away while
you're pregnant
yeah so that would be a bummer for you
you wouldn't get to have your Ms excuse
I don't have MS I've gotten a lot of
testing to rule it out for now I did do
a really hard leg day and I was like oh
really and Todd had to like like skirt
me around like he had to like help me
walk around it was that bad and I was
like this does feel like he's like
training to deal with
this is really going to sound really
morbid but one of my best friends
she's really into quad play so where she
pretends she's a quadriple oh my god of
course who isn't and so she you never
did that you never just I'm levied up
I've never he never does heavied up I'm
definitely listening have you never just
body weighted I'm definitely all ears
okay listen but she goes a little too
far right so she drools she has to be
like flipped on her side and you know so
she doesn't get the bed sores like she
goes along the character for hours you
guys
no to her husband I could see you having
to take this
like you can do this yeah her husband
works for ExxonMobil
you can do this
of Dave is not allowed to act like this
of Dave has tried
update will be very single if Dave tries
to do that of Todd you think that so
you've heavied heavied up oh yeah what
are you talking about you stiff up and
then they have to carry you around they
have to dress you
you've never done that you've never been
like dressed me I've definitely done
that it's so fun and you step up and
they get mad at you they do start to get
really mad because they don't know that
you're going to do the bit for that long
you just see how long they get
pissed it does usually end up with me
naked lying like this in my bed going
like Todd but you guys I don't think
quad plays a real terms
it's so up but telecommunications
quadruple is coming up that's
I can call her and ask her
like what she does this who is his
friend it's just a friend of mine we
might we're gonna have to bleep out her
name okay
I think that's a good idea
okay
you're good you're doing it now
I will say a man putting on socks for
you is like there's nothing you do how
many boners you just gave out saying
that
do you know how many men would love to
put your socks on for you line them up
boys line up should I sell feet pictures
pay for my wedding hey I have a question
for you oh you're on the Pod by the way
I should say that out loud can you
describe to me um quad play when you
play a quadriplegic
oh she sounds so hot by the way
she's like quad
I'm getting one
attraction disability I have that what
is it because I explained that our
friendship
oh God she's not picking up anymore
she was down though yeah yeah yeah
she'll call back okay
okay oh yeah hi you've reached my phone
number and my full name
oh my goodness okay not to bring up a
movie from literally 10 years ago but
have you guys seen Shutter Island yeah a
long time ago okay
it's so good I did not understand it the
first time I saw it because I was a
child I was only 25 but
um
when you realize and there's spoilers
but like at the end that this is all an
elaborate role play for him to pretend
he's a detective my first thought was
like that's like if someone did that for
me like spent all that budget and like
Albert labor into like a role play to
like help me work out my mental illness
like is that what this show is like
that's so sweet I don't know there's no
show this has never aired
this has been a very long intervention
for you we wouldn't even acknowledge our
should we acknowledge we finally have
like sexy tank tops wait these are so
cute I know we have trash Tuesday tank
tops that are probably available right
now not yet
well they will be when this comes out
well then
no one can say
okay well maybe maybe not there's a
there's an Intrigue about them there's a
mystery mystery we like to play hard to
get
yes that's why for five years we haven't
had any merges okay here she is here she
is
sorry I don't know why the call failed
but um will you explain to us quad play
like when I pretend like I'm paralyzed
yes
okay so basically
it's a bedroom game border born of
boredom
so you just see how much she loves you
and you start like pretending
that you have no
you have no like response to any of his
anything and you just lay there and he
kind of just like flap around like a
dead fish and you wait for him to notice
and then do you but does he like flip
you over like are you drooling like
what's the vibe
I'm I
should drooling but usually I'll like
cross like I'll cross my eyes and I'll
like let I'll let my hands just be like
on the sides of my body he doesn't ever
he's like not um
he doesn't care enough to flip me over
anymore okay but once upon a time he did
what does sex happen once upon I don't
think he ever did
okay she's on her boyfriend
like mine but does sex happen
the sex would happen oh okay yeah goes
to completion but he's just like okay
having like she's being silly and
anxious
this is how she handles herself and he's
like he's just like no worries he just
goes he's like it's fine like do you but
I'm gonna go ahead and finish my thing
okay thank you thank you for explaining
that I'll call you later love you you're
a hero bye
no it's fun to go very stiff
it's fun to be like this
so
historically what I've done is mostly I
do the same I heavy up but face down
like ass up yeah because I don't want to
see anyone's face wait did you guys see
Bo's afraid yeah no not yet okay there's
a scene where I don't want to say who it
is because it's actually so exciting
it's actually the best just say who it
is because you said this last time it
was Parker Posey oh okay who you've
always wanted to see Parker Posey's tits
right like she's so incredible I'm not
against it but I had never had that
thought before I once you see him you go
oh my God this is like all I've ever
wanted like I can't believe ariaster
pulled this off and gave us our dreams
but she like
I don't want to get this is like it's
really like the the movie's so horrific
that this is really the only really the
best part but she's like she dies like
like having sex with them so she's like
rigor mortis like
and like position and this is what
you you love this so much now it's your
new Nickelback that's why you bring it
back which by the way I almost wore that
but Todd was wearing our Nickelback
shirt we I did forget that Nickelback's
has the song Not nickelbacks Sorry
Nickelback has the song Rockstar yes
it's the best song and it is the best
song it's the number one song but you
know what sucked at the concert they
someone had won a contest so this girl
came up and like sang it I was like she
karaokeed it I was like guys we're here
for Rockstar they can't do that we are
here for Rockstar maybe I can get them
to come on and do it on our show I'm in
I'm fully this just lifts up and
Nickelback's behind us that's so perfect
to be in a our basement with Nickelback
Chad wanted nothing to do the meet and
greet was was shocking how little
attention I got I couldn't believe it
Michael gave me everything but they
moved me on very I don't know the names
but Chad's the
the main guy okay who used to be married
to Avril Lavigne whoa yeah that's a good
use to be married to Avril does not have
a type
no she sounds like me Avril dates and
Mary's look how beautiful Parker Posey
is I feel like you are into Asian men
if I have dated the whole spectrum of
anything height even I've gone from six
five to four foot eleven like there's
four foot eleven okay so I have I
literally have a chance literally yeah
but it's it's I would love to see a
picture with you on your four foot
eleven I know was that not Bobby he was
Bobby's four foot eleven guys he just
wears those little like lifters on his
shoes yeah Avro can we get a list of
avril's relationships yeah she dated the
guy from sum 41.
I think she married she married a couple
of these guys yeah Brody Brody Jenner
Brody Jenner who I actually love Brody
Jenner I did a thing with him
and we had a blast what did you
do with him what's the thing we did like
we did a thing we did a what do you call
like testing pilot testing okay together
it was so fun was he like cool yeah he
was the best okay so one Brody Jenner
thing that I've always just personally
like it's been an Esther flag for me a
beige flag
um is I noticed that he was a really big
Elvis fan and he was wearing some kind
of like Elvis like jewelry and that's
his mom's ex-boyfriend and I'm kind of
like isn't that weird who's his mom's
ex-boyfriend Elvis his mom is Linda I
forget her last name but she dated Elvis
she was dating Elvis I think when he
passed away and she was like a big
girlfriend for him post Priscilla and
I'm like that's crazy that your mom
dated Elvis it's like wouldn't you be a
little bit anti your mom's ex like no
but he's only the ex he died that's why
he's the ex
they didn't break up but shouldn't you
if you're okay shouldn't you hate all
the men who your mom besides your
own dad
not if they were nice to you I don't
know I think you shouldn't because Dad
is
is Caitlyn Jenner I think whatever dad
he can get he's probably very happy to
have
and his two dads are Elvis and an
Olympian
I think he's doing okay okay and woman
of the year he literally has he has
his dads are the top type of dads you
can have I just personally if your penis
was my mom and you didn't make me I
don't want anything to do with you what
if your penis is in
your mom and then
you are a woman of the year
this show is sponsored by Better Health
get a break from yourself get a break
from your friends
for me last night I go you know what
Esther I think it's time to call better
help you FaceTime me yes but it was a
longer one than I thought I saw your
lizards and were they therapeutic what
actually made me a lot better so I was
like I'm glad I'm not surrounded by
lizards guys when when better help isn't
available you can always FaceTime my
lizards if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge but can
I just say like sometimes I'm trying to
fall asleep and the thoughts just like
come alive like a circus yeah and it's
really hard and I do need a break for my
thoughts and I have found that talking
to someone in talk therapy is kind of
the only real way to achieve that and I
do love better help for that reason I
also love better health because they
have a journal feature where you can
write down your thoughts in between your
appointments and then you can bring that
up
um with your therapist the next time you
see them you know you get to that point
where you're just you've called all your
friends and they know and you get this
straight to voicemail and you go oh no
and you don't want to be sharing that
stuff with your friends they don't need
to hear you you need unbiased
opinion because I have it happen to me
too like my friends will call me
Non-Stop and they call you at weird
hours where it's like anxious hours and
you're like no no no normal person is
just calling you to tell you some good
news at this hour you know what you need
to say to them get a break from your
thoughts with better help visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help
help.com trash Tuesday we've all used it
we all really love it and need it so
thank you better help you guys I got my
quip starter kit and I got a water
flosser I'm like oh that's why I've had
bad breath for 30 years I mean I
honestly can't believe I didn't send
this to you sooner it's I mean even next
to you every day it feels so it's the
best it's literally better than sex like
the water just me it's so it's like a
water park in your mouth it's somehow as
satisfying as drinking water it Annie do
not use it here
it works very well and it seriously will
hurt I'm not sure it's not aimed at you
can I attack kalilah you guys this water
flosser hits all the right spots with
gentle or deep clean pressure at the
touch of a button no but can I tell you
I've always wanted a water flosser but
they're so ugly and quip makes one the
quip is like the apple of Dental
products like look at how Chic this is
the other ones you see like are so ugly
and not okay and also I use my quip
toothbrush for travel or like I've
always used mine like if I'm working on
set I bring it and that's like my sexy
girl toothbrush and you can TSA will
think this is a sex
uh product but that's what we want
that's what we want and you can um you
can track and improve your brushing
habits too with using the free quip app
you can earn amazing rewards like free
refills products Target gift cards and
more with stylish and Affordable
Electric brushes starting at just 25 you
won't be paying through the teeth for
better oral health also the toothbrushes
are smart electric toothbrushes so they
have sensitive Sonic vibrations for an
effective clean that's gentle on on your
sensitive gums which I have and a lot of
times people with electric toothbrushes
will brush too hard and it's too
abrasive but quip will not let you do
that like it's the perfect amount take
care of your gums and if you go to
quip.com trash Tuesday right now you get
20 off any electric toothbrush mint and
gum dispenser water flosser that's 20
off any electric toothbrush mint and gum
dispenser water flosser at getquip.com
trash Tuesday spell
g-t-quip.com trash Tuesday quip the good
habits open your mouth
thank you Annie
this is the coolest gum dispenser ever
I've never had a gum dispenser but I'll
tell you actually you know what I have
the gum dispenser was the tape the
bubble tape and this is way better I'm a
grown-up now okay and it's so Chic look
at that okay thank you they also have my
favorite thing which is the slim travel
ready dispenser available in five colors
metal or plastic it's a pack and it
protects up to 10 pieces of gum or mints
at a time and fits in just about any
purse or pocket on the go like it's so
much secret to have your gum or mince in
like a little mysterious dispenser as
opposed to like
I don't know when I just think of what's
in my purse before this it's not good
also I have add this is a thing it
sticks on your your wall so you don't
you just have a place for your
toothbrush I am always like where am I I
have 52 pictures I have 25 kids like
this it's a slap bracelet you're just
bleeding
wait I have a question for you guys and
what if your vagina is in your mom it
was
it there's a penis in Whitney Cummings
right now wherever she is there's a
penis in her
because she's not because she's
it's because she's having a son just to
be clear so funny yeah
I know I would not want a boy I don't
want a penis in me
I I literally think I thought about this
and I was like I was looking in the
mirror I was like would Esther be like a
boy mom or a girl looking in the mirror
I was I was like gazing into my own soul
I was like huh I randomly was just
thinking that
what about you I feel like you would be
a really good guy mom yeah but I've only
ever dreamed of having girls me too and
then all my embryos are boys yeah
that's probably gonna be my fate I I
have this feeling that because I want a
girl so bad that I'll probably just have
boys
um one pro I will say that I've recently
been thinking about is if you have a boy
then like
you know that's someone else's
responsibility to teach it's for it's
like there's a lot off your plate if
it's a boy but if I'm the athletic one
no my mom was like if Bobby and I would
have had a kid yeah if Bobby and I would
have had a kid do you think that he
would be the guy to teach he'd teach
them all the video games no video games
yes you would yeah I um yeah I think
about it because the embryos were so
expensive it is good that they're boys
because they can like make the money
back
for me easier wait how much were they
in total I think I paid over thirty
thousand dollars for all the oh my wow
but I don't know I didn't it was all in
different increments and I blacked out
yeah
I saw I was like I'm not counting this
anymore because I had to do it or I
would have no I'm glad I would have died
I'm really glad you did it I would have
died like I do fully think you're gonna
get pregnant naturally but I'm just glad
that you have it
get closer have a little penis in me
okay so I have a question for you guys
um it's about this thing called the good
boy text and basically like in your past
like after sleeping with a boy in order
to see see them again do you require the
good boy text which is the next morning
say for instance like what is your rule
with
okay I'm gonna do this again with this
guy if he shows me this thing is it a
text before noon is it a text
um
you know immediately like what do you
consider like courteous Behavior
there is no text the next day
don't ever don't ever to call me again
like that's CR that's upset well they
didn't want to I can speak for all of
them
they're relieved to hear this like I
can't imagine I think that is the rudest
thing to have even if it's like and it's
they're trying to play a game but it's
so it really is just like why if you
spent the night with me would you not
the next day be like yeah like who
raised you it's like no manners just on
a baseline even like no manners
I and because I have I'm so anxiously
attached that it's like when people go
into that gameplay which is why the
gameplay works because it like ignites
your anxiously attached yeah it's a slot
machine it's horrible but I think girls
have caught on I think that we don't we
no longer respond well to a guy playing
that game of being I'm gonna wait a
little bit to see like make herself for
a little bit make her a little insecure
it's like no no no no no no I did have a
guy once who
we had like a really good night together
it was really fun and then he like
didn't call me all day and I was so
surprised like I really was surprised
because he was only in town for like a
couple weeks I was just like oh that's
so weird and then
um
he called me that afternoon he's like I
went to the zoo and my phone died and I
was like oh thank God like it was like
so nice it was like a good well the last
guy that I hooked up with I to even
avoid all of that like right after I
slept with him and he left that morning
I basically said if you don't text me it
will really hurt my feelings like if I
don't get a text like plan on never
seeing me again and he was like of
course I'm gonna text you but I put it
out there immediately I think that's the
way to go yeah I'm like dude don't be
rude okay like we just please
text because if you think about it if
you're worried about seeming too clingy
or anything that's coming from an
insecurity too and that's also not
saying that to them is gameplay yeah
like not so not like wanting to seem
like you're not like if you want to see
that person again that's the truth about
it you don't want to come on so strong
obviously you don't want to go like
overboard because your feelings are
fresh anyways you don't really know but
that's good it's just to be like yeah
call me I told him it's like I'm
sensitive about this stuff please call
me please text now here's what I wonder
because you said like oh I feel like
women have we realize now that we don't
play with games whatever I wonder though
is that our age or is that everyone
yeah because I think at a younger age
you're more likely to excuse bad
behavior whereas now it's just like
you're off my roster I don't have the
time for this but I have a single friend
who's like you know in our age range and
she recently told me she you know had a
great date with a guy and on that date
he was like I just want you to know I'm
not playing there's not gonna be any
games like I'm not there's none of that
and
when she told me that I was like oh my
God I love him this is great I just love
that he set that out and he didn't call
I do think it is generational too so
it's like if they grew up with the game
being the thing and the way to go and
it's all everything in life is about
whether guys got laid or not in high
school right right it's all that it's
all like were you popular in high school
did you get in high school
it's like every male comic that's the
ones out there like banging everyone is
because they're like they are now in a
position where they can I have so many
guys I'm so mad at women because they
didn't like them when they were young
and ugly I know my dad was talking about
incels he's like there's like a problem
with that I'm like yeah but there's this
underlying you blaming women for that
too
yeah and then there's this other thing
of like
you know the high value woman where
you're like also not supposed to be a
anymore so it's like okay how are
we gonna bang the angry up in
cells and also behind them somebody
there's a there's nothing it's not
working here do we want to stop the
school shootings or do we want like to
wait till marriage this is why we all
want to live in the handmaid's tale they
figured a system out for us correct and
what's it called I forgot the name of
their Town
um the what is it called no this is the
worst themed once in Boston once upon a
time I was trying to watch it last night
Todd wanted to watch murder wait I will
say though in the scenes and handmaid's
tale that got me the most was like when
they would flash back and in the first
season and you'd see Boston and you'd
like see the real American city and the
slow changes that like it's one
thing the fantasy world where it where
it's this crazy different like whole
different Community but when you see the
slow changes it's like the Gilead
thank you I was just like I would ball
my eyes out like this is and how Canada
wasn't for it yeah but they had to do
diplomatic stuff with them a little bit
like it was yeah which is so that's like
real politics stuff like that's you
gotta play with the bad guys when all of
a sudden all the women's bank accounts
got shut down
would be Todd would be like uh our card
isn't working
we went out to breakfast I was like Fork
it up cough it up
I have um
are you
how much does it matter to you if your
partner makes more or less than you he
must make glass and I'm just kidding
um
Esther
I don't know because when I was
dating I was so broke that like
there was died if they made less money
but then again I did date guys who made
the same I don't
I don't know but they were ambitious
I think that's what it is for me right
it's like effort yeah the guys you dated
had Futures they weren't gonna like be
broke you never know you really never
know I think that that's a dangerous
game the whole like he's got potential
is a dangerous game earning potential
matters I do earning potential is
different from other kinds of potential
like I think he could there's a good guy
underneath all of this potential is a
dangerous game yeah okay true but if you
look at someone and they're ambitious
they're hungry they're talented and you
know they're probably gonna get
somewhere they're just not there yet
then it's like oh yeah like yeah you
can't help the guys like I dated a guy
who was like very reliant on me he would
he kept saying he wanted to do com like
it was so gross I was a professional
comedian and he was like I yeah I want
to do comedy and he wouldn't do it and
I'm like all right I'm already seeing
the signs of someone that's never going
to do the thing that they say they want
to do that's a thing I'm showing you in
front of you that you can do it was like
so I knew he was always gonna struggle
with money he was never gonna make money
ever no matter what he did and
um
and then he used wanting to do comedy
and not doing it as a way to not get a
job that actually paid him good money
it was very weird I don't know if that's
relatable or too specific but for me I
think that I'm very much okay dating
someone who um doesn't make as much as
me as long as number one there's effort
number two there's some earning
potential but also more importantly like
if we're out on a date like it doesn't
matter what we're doing like I want you
to pay
um and that's I don't know what it is
it's like super traditional or whatever
but there's that just gesture of taking
me out on a date it's important for me
but
um I feel like I almost don't have that
as much like
I don't know why I think as I probably
am very used to like splitting and like
just from the early days I don't know
like to me there's something about
dinner that's not that important to me
but what I what you were saying it's
like
a person needs to have something going
on that they're passionate about and I
understand what you guys are saying
about earning potential and yes like
especially if you guys are young but
I've seen like so often where when a guy
is not really where he wants to be he's
not in my experience like able to be a
good partner yeah I also you're there's
a fear of that resentment growing like
for me it's like I'm okay if someone
makes less than me as long as they're
okay and they don't secretly feel
emasculated yes that is the worst if
they feel better yeah because if you're
masculine any hinges on your financial
status and then now you feel less than
me and now you're taking it out on me in
ways that like I you know and that's so
real matters to that much go make more
money yeah but get a side hustle or do
something right if that is if that is
your number one value is like showing
that you can provide and you have more
money then you have to figure out
how to do that it comes out on me to
make less money yes yeah yeah and I do
feel like that's a very this is like the
plight of successful women like I feel
like it's talked about in society a lot
where like they have so many less
options because there's a lot of men
that are intimidated by a woman who
makes more than them and so like they're
it's just harder today there's a lot of
people that don't care about that trust
me no I agree and I think a confident
secure man doesn't care yeah but I think
there's
I think there's like it's a good
question because it's like it's it is
tricky I don't know yeah I think you
would have to be very secure and
um
I don't know like lead in other ways
that aren't like Financial right like
because that's me is like attractive
yeah but um I think that a guy who in
when I was in my 20s who made a ton
more money than me
but he was the least generous person I
had ever met in my life when they're
making so much money and you're like can
you just like
and I'm like what are you doing I
remember one time like I
he was making let's suppose like on a
day like twelve thousand dollars to get
a day when we were like on the road when
he was doing what he was doing or
whatever but he would have a sleep no he
would have a sleep there would be like a
Travelodge right next to where we he was
working on the road but he opted for his
the back of the kitchen of his friend's
restaurant where he had all these Crisco
boxes and that's where he we had a blow
up mattress there was no hot water this
was in San Francisco and we
slept there for like a whole week and we
couldn't he couldn't even spring for
sixty dollars a day at the Travelodge
was like right there and I remember
having to shower at the 24 Hour
Fitness in the marina was he a broke kid
no he went to the international school
in Belgium like
it's like so like really just tight with
his and I remember breaking out
really bad eczema that week and being
like I gotta go shower at the 24 Hours
come on we got free Crisco right here so
I mean like there are people like that
so it doesn't matter I think if
you're like that though because I know
so many people so many women that love
like a deal they love not spending a lot
of money that would probably be
attracted to someone that wants to do
that too yeah that guy was just not for
me I just don't have that I like I want
people that like spend more than they
have I'm like let's go crazy who gives a
and then I dated a middle school
math teacher who was the most generous
guy on earth like he never let me pay
for anything and we made the same amount
but that's the kind of I'm saying it
doesn't really matter like someone could
be Filthy Rich and just
really tight with her
which is foreign
[Music]
I have 80d so I would always like I had
it it was like so hard to pay attention
because if you you know Daydream for a
second you're like wait where are we but
I loved it how far up did you go I only
went to Algebra 2 because I graduated
early oh Algebra 2 is all you need to I
wanted to do calculus though I always
have like a weird dream that I'm going
to somehow do calculating I don't think
I took calculus either I don't know why
I got caught cheating in college
um for calc 2.
you got caught cheating yeah oh my God
there's a slap on the wrist I never went
to a school where there was anyone
monitoring whether you were cheating or
not everyone was just like just get
through this
it's a miracle you're here
that's like the places I waited tables
to were like always like
you don't have to memorize any specials
I always did very low maintenance low
well I found oh my God I recently found
my old Johnny Rockets
dress
and I have two of them so we should oh I
guess we already did waitress theme but
that waitress theme did not count funny
how she thinks either of us could fit
into a second we'd have to keep them
busted open the back you guys
my mom
um we went on Family Video wait did I
say Johnny Rockets Hard Rock Hard Rock
Cafe
wait what was the Hard Rock um what was
the Hard Rock
um ensemble a really cute black like
mini dress really yeah like it's cute
you guys like it's sexy with a collar
yeah and like pins there's a big pin
culture at Hard Rock Cafe and I'm not
I'm not proud to say that I did get
sucked into it how long were you there
oh you don't know I so was the new one
that was opening on Hollywood Boulevard
and I worked the whole training process
and I failed the test and I was demoted
to guests and I never got to make it to
opening day
they were like you have to stay and I
was like I have shows in La Jolla
tonight and they were like wait but
don't you have to buy the uniform so you
hey I have them yeah she bought two
how many is this one pin no there's how
many pins can you get in training a lot
you can get a lot okay but I had a
disadvantage because I never drink
alcohol so I could not memorize all
these like alcoholic drinks I was like
there's no I was like I'm gonna get by
on personality and that was not really a
strategy that worked it worked for me my
entire life I've never memorized
anything when I was a bartender I was
like I was just I don't know how I had
that job I didn't know how to make any
drink I don't know how I got through
and everyone loved me I was just like
blonde privilege wait I have questions
for you off Todd enough Dave
um how do we feel about pet names
okay the only pet name I don't like I
had a boyfriend who called me my pet
and baby head
what baby that's kind of cute but I was
friends with him when he was like with
his girlfriend before me and they were
the same names oh
I know and they grossed me out when he
said them to her or me
so he called you baby head baby and he
called her baby head yeah oh yeah that's
not cool I think I've got a pet no this
guy I think I've got a no pet name
policy yeah you don't seem like a pet
name kind of girl that's not so you've
never called what do you get called babe
hun sweetie
hey you hey hey bro are you going back
to Bros again bro my bro
yeah I don't you don't get called babe
yeah what is it how did I call each
other Beau oh yeah I've heard both so
cute is that just because Bo is afraid
was your favorite movie no that's why we
liked going to it because we're like
this is our no it's like he always calls
me Boba is from American Idol Oh my God
so zero so you call Dave Dave and he
calls you Esther yeah donut you have you
called donut well donut has pet names
like a million a zillion pet names when
you hear other people use pet names does
it bother you is this a register I don't
think you're registered but I think if I
did like I sort of take the stance from
the Seinfeld episode where like Jerry is
dating that girl and she calls him
schmoopy it's like oh he's rough
I like like being cute and stuff but I
don't know about pet names
I don't know do you did you and Bobby
have them but I haven't called him Bobby
in a decade I still don't he has a
problem him and I are we don't know each
other's names we don't know each other's
names and he still we still publicly use
babe and sweetheart and it is it's been
a problem it's hard to undo years and
years of calling someone Bo or babe or
sweetheart or you being so endearing in
that way
I sometimes I accidentally call my Mambo
[Laughter]
I'll call my parents my love but it's
cute yeah my love is one of my favorites
so love is always I use love
um but even when he texts still it's
like babe can you do this for me call my
husband a lot I call him my husband oh
that's cute do you think you'll
do the husband wife
you'll do it what do you mean get
married I do think I will because when I
first got engaged it was annoying that
everyone was asking me so I was like
yeah and it just feels so overwhelming
to consider planning a what are
you talking about and didn't I say this
on the podcast before it's like I have a
wedding every night every night a bunch
of people come to celebrate me every
single night I do that he's like I
gotta plan another one but um
but then over uh summer over my vacation
Todd couldn't come but my dad and I went
over to Todd's parents house and we're
all hanging out and I was like oh it is
really yeah you went to Todd's parents
house yeah me and my dad drove to Jersey
and just hung out with his parents that
is so cute and his mom cooked as
now was the only reason Todd couldn't go
because he had to babysit the reptiles
no honestly I was thinking about the
block of these reptiles they're
starting to really piss me off because
there's so many of them there's three
snakes
he was like being so cocky he's like my
champagne boa I don't know what kind of
does he's like we'll never buy it she's
so cute literally 10 seconds later but
him
is he okay
he doesn't care yeah but so okay so
three snakes we did get the um
three snakes three geckos
Five Frogs
so cute any Turtles coming through the
pipeline because Esther is begging for
it I don't know I want a turtle named
Duster
bester Esther oh Esther a best arrestor
this is my bestest
oh wait what yeah what is it like you
had a turtle you are turtle-like now
that you're just mentioning it yeah but
a turtle is forever it's slow I could
see you sluggish not not mentally slow
and I could see tipping you on your back
and you're not being able to get up
struggling
I could see it kind of also having to
you know tortoises need to be buried for
like half the year to hibernate would
you want to just be buried and to let be
allowed to sleep for half the Year yes
I've often talked about this fantasy I
have where I I wish people could like
die for two weeks and come back
like think about how much you'd
appreciate life if you like in a coma or
dead for two weeks and then you got to
come back this weirdly reminded me of
this but this is not actually that
related I really want to go do one of
those vipassana silent Retreats which we
all know it's gonna be very difficult
you have no chance but you have no
chance but Jared Leto during I don't
know if I brought this up in here before
but during the pandemic he did the he
was on a silent retreat
so when he came out everything was shut
down
they're so funny isn't that and he was
like what's happening
he didn't know what the was going
he was like a week late to everything
this is like my favorite moment in in
U.S history when James Cameron was at
the bottom like of the Titanic like
having him and um Bill Paxton had lunch
on the Titanic like literally in a
submarine on the bow of the Titanic they
come up and someone's like hey so
someone just hit the Twin Towers
um it's kind of a big deal and you like
in this documentary you see them find
out and it's it's kind of crazy it's
yeah
you guys I just discovered a new ick
and I feel like it's a very unfair ick
but it's an ick nonetheless
so I recently watched a boy shower okay
how he arched his back to wash his butt
I know we got we might need to upgrade
boy what do you mean oh man man you just
stared right into me yeah well you're I
mean you went like this sorry there's a
hole in my pants yeah don't apologize
this is why I feel it's really unfair
because how true how else could a man
really wash his butt in the shower but
basically he did a tiny little quick
Arch Back to wash his butt
and I did not like bearing witness to it
that's horrible I was like oh I I'm
really troubled right now really isn't
it it's funny it's also when they eat
you when they're going down on you and
they're you see the yeah you see what
when they're this up instead of down
it's like please please dangle your legs
they're like you're like please like
tight core yeah I don't want the ass up
if you're going down on me that is so
that is I'm I will never unsee that I I
have never opened my eyes when someone's
going down I'm always like covering my
face like I know I need it like pitch
black wait I would you're right watching
a man shower sounds horrible but I'm
telling you the back arch will undo all
the love you've ever had
oh my God if that was an egg for me Todd
and I would be done Todd do you remember
when I got like the
the tie up the like ties and I come in
and Todd's tied himself up I'm like how
are you the tied up one time
I just pushed him off the bed he like
clunked over wait he thought the ties
were for him he was kidding but it's
like it is his jokes lean a little
arched up
hahaha
it is so hard when like if guys want the
kind of treatment that you want it's
like if I hooked up with a guy who
wanted me to choke him
I was like you want me to choke you what
happened to you me
I'm the girl yeah we have to keep up the
alarm I'm the victim
what am I Lorena Bobbitt like what is
going on here there's like two of us Amy
Fisher there's been two pegged no but I
recently
um a friend of mine told me the funniest
pegging story so she uh there's full
arch with pegging by the way yeah it's
full Arch so a friend of mine was
briefly married to this guy and she
always had a thing she has a thing I
like when a pegging story starts with a
very short marriage a very short
marriage
so she had always wanted she likes
thrusting so she was like I think I want
to Peg somebody and so she broached a
subject with her partner thinking he was
gonna be like absolutely not oh my God
more than that so she was like Hey like
would you be interested in like being
pegged and he was like
he had everything prepared including the
the dildo itself everything he had
already he he like Unearthed this
treasure chest of all the things that he
had used in the past because he had he
like being pegged but so he got high on
I don't know what opiates one night and
she was pegging him in the living room
and he himself and like passed out
and she had to clean up
no she didn't have to but she did
because he was just gone I would just be
like you know what you're gonna wake up
and deal with this I'm going in the
other room okay question should
should men or should everyone get pegged
should some of us in you know men and
women or whoever you are keep some of
our sexual desires to ourselves like
should he like not tell the audience no
I'm really just questioning in my head
I'm like should he have
is it good that he was honest or should
he have been like this is too risky it's
not worth it like but imagine just like
Imagine The Joy he must have felt being
a guy who likes being pegged but two may
be afraid to put her off you manifested
it yeah one day she's like hey you want
to try this thing and he's like oh my
God that's my most favorite thing in the
world like you wouldn't be able to say
no to that
okay but okay Counterpoint like some
people are
and they're sexually attracted to
Children why does she always bring this
up so like should it is like the third
time no but I'm just saying like two
months they should not act on that and
they should keep that to themselves so
yes because it's illegal can I just say
something all the hallucinogens I've
done okay everything I do it always
comes down to but what about
every like life like where it's like
everything I learn all the work I do is
like forgive like accept love like don't
judge and then I'm like but what about
the
you know well and I just want to tap out
but I can't it's like
Ayahuasca I'm like I learn all these
less I go oh my God we're all one we're
this loving vibration and then I'm like
Jared from Subway is like I'm like I
just don't
is like the exception where I am like I
don't
forgive them you know on that I feel bad
for them I guess I don't know no I'm
with you on that I think you're oh like
that's good like you're allowed to feel
that way there's nothing wrong with what
you just said but it is like if someone
came to me and was like I have to tell
you a secret I like so I would be like
get away from me
but I will say what you just said I'll
point out as you said you do feel bad
for them
or I don't or I don't or I actually
don't I don't know
I don't know
okay it's like too hard it's like yeah
I also think that
yeah that makes it's like a puzzle yeah
but there's like I was talking to this
woman that was doing she did um like
body work like Reiki type stuff on me
and she was saying she's like a lot of
men come to her
uh who have the urges but they don't
they their whole life is about not ever
being around kids and making sure that
they're
like whatever they can do to not act on
it so she's like there's a difference
between that and then yeah agree so how
do you feel about hearing about those
people
is it again you want to cut your balls
off you want to go live in the woods
like that's nice I think that if you do
have that urge you do need to sound the
alarm on yourself I do think it's
something you should I mean I mean how
do you outwardly say like hey I have an
attraction to this you know that child
it's so up that's scary that's
scary but like The Honorable thing would
be to say hey I I thought something is
wrong with me get some
accountability going yeah like can
someone help me because I know this is
wrong I know this is up can
someone help me
right yeah because I think repressing it
and not saying it out loud maybe makes
it even a bigger thing in your body
yeah and it might well it's bad it's
like with food and you're like oh that's
a bad it's so bad yeah oh you brought
like literally every time I'm like I'm
not having any sweets by three o'clock
that day I've stuffed to the guild three
pints of ice cream like I just go crazy
she's just a little pumpkin filled with
candy on Halloween memories I'm gonna
shove candy in your mouth thank you
until you come yes what do you think of
this if an ex
if an X reaches back out or if an X
reaches out to you is it always sus or
can it ever be a genuine check-in
foreign
oh my God I think it's always like weird
and not yeah
how long okay I've lived in a lot of
small towns
so in small towns there's different that
sounds like the first sentence of a book
actually the truth is I've lived in one
small town and then I've gone to small
schools
and you are forced
to be to have different relationships
with people even if you dated them like
you kind of like have to be friends
because everyone there's uh do you know
what I mean yeah
yeah and but I will say
I'm going to New Mexico and I was like
oh should I go say hi to Mike and then I
was like I guess not
oh I think you should I think I mean go
meet his kids and stuff life experience
if you guys are already genuinely
friends and it's not sus if you've
maintained a friendship after the
breakup then it's not sus right but if
it's a random like
I think it can be genuine in that like
you know
for instance the fires in Maui like I
had to check in with an ex I felt like
that was a general I felt like I had to
check in with them thank you but I
didn't but I I was thinking about you
bud but I was like oh my God like I hope
he's okay was he on that side of the
island no he wasn't but
um I think um you're right there's right
times to do it like your phone ex's
parent passed away
I think that's like a really well do
they not want to talk to you are
they like maybe I don't want to judge
this up either I also think like I feel
really good when I resist the urge to
talk to an ex or like my my like high
school friend that we had all this drama
and stuff she has this really successful
um restaurant
and when I was home I was like I had
this urge to like go to the restaurant
and be like
you know like see like be like Oh I'm
proud or whatever and then I'm like I'm
not doing that felt really good yeah
because I always have to stop and ask
myself if when I feel that urge to be
like oh I just want to say hi I'm like
do I want to say hi or do I want a
specific kind of attention that I know
he usually gives me
um so like most of the time the answer
is the latter and I have to in that
moment be like okay like I
shouldn't do that if the answer is oh I
genuinely want to know like if he's okay
if he's whatever if his mom has just
passed or whatever yeah how's your
family if but yes there's a difference
but if a guy okay we're talking about us
reaching out to our exes but what about
when they reach out to us like out of
the blue random is it always oh my God I
had a x that's been hitting me up it's
it just depends because I I have slept
with him several times since we broke up
we dated when we were like in our early
20s
and the last time I was like I'm never
going back to this again I'm done but
it's like he wasn't done so he still
thinks that door is open and it's I just
will never respond to him ever again
right I mean it's pretty obvious you're
in a long-term relationship at this
point I think that makes sense yeah but
I also don't trust guys like with when
when they hit me up out of the blue I'm
like the reason that I usually leave
them on red or don't respond it's
because I don't trust them with the
little I give them where it's like if I
give them an inch he'll take a mile I'd
like oh yeah I don't even want them to
think that they can ever have me again
so if I give them just a little bit I
know they'll go home thinking yeah I
could still hit that and I don't want
that yeah like you can't you really
can't you never will and um I think
that's smart I always forget that guys
think like just because you acknowledge
them that then that makes them think
that you won't you'll have sex with them
yeah it's so annoying Todd said to me
once he was like every open maker in Los
Angeles thinks I can have sex with you I
was like no no because they do and I'm
like it makes me so mad I'm like Todd
don't bring any of your old open
microphones near me ever
now okay you said that you you're gonna
go to Santa Fe and you might reconnect
with it but I don't think I will because
I'm like I don't really like if I run
into people I run into them you know
it's like
I don't even know what the friend group
is going on I lived in Santa Fe for
seven years so I went through like a lot
of different lives there and a lot of
different people move and then your
friend group just completely changes so
I don't know who's still connected who
even lives there it's like I've just hit
up like two or three friends and but I
do kind of want to rent a scooter and
Scoot around like I used to I think a
hundred percent you should do that just
go see what's up I mean I have a
question for you both when you both got
in engaged similar to maybe how I felt
in the pandemic did you feel the need to
kind of like
I don't know take stock of your life up
until that point like be like wait
and maybe go full it to Mama tambian
and just kind of well have you seen that
movie no
well there was a gang bang there's a
game yes uncircumcised penises it's
really like by the pool side it was
great I think because literally the
second I locked eyes with Dave I wanted
him to propose to me like there was no
like one to happen there was no like
poor Dave he felt it
she was like oh no like there was it was
just like okay like there was no looking
back for me at all because I wanted it
so badly I just yeah
I I feel like I would have a moment of
being like oh like I kind of wanna
you know take a walk down memory no I
definitely had like I don't think of
like it was like a week of just I think
I talked about in one of the episodes
like just of like thinking about every
guy I had seriously yeah heard about I
went through all of them but I don't
have it I have this because it's like
it's like basically taking inventory of
everything and everyone you've been with
up until the point of finally finding
your person like I think I'm similar to
you where it's like how did I get here
what just happened and then you kind of
retrace the last 10 years of your life
or the last 15 did you feel that way
I was just thinking I was like oh that's
like it was just interesting because I'm
like okay this is where I've landed this
is like what I want I'm happy in this in
this storyline but I definitely like
played out something I was like oh
that's like so interesting because it is
like there were I didn't have that many
boyfriends where I was like saw like
them as like my person or thought maybe
they could be there were a lot of like
filler boyfriends but there were like
two I like that term there I mean just
where I'm like well how am I still here
and you know what I was thinking too
turning 40 I was thinking back and I'm
so happy that I have like my partner and
my person and I just feel really good
with where I'm at but I was thinking
like there are a lot of insecurities
that have come with my birthday and I'm
like
if like if I was single right now I
would be so pissed at the two
boyfriends I had before Todd for wasting
my reproductive years like
I would be so mad at them because they
just weren't
they wouldn't they would take my time
but they wouldn't give it to me I relate
to that I will admit that a big part of
I had a fear I this is you're just
making this come up for me but like with
Dave I had that fear I was like if this
doesn't work out like these are my best
years I tell Bobby that all the time he
wasted my firm skin years he squandered
my firm skin years I mean we broke up
when I was what like 36.
like but at least you spend all
those firm skin years on camera so
that's good you did capture that yeah
also I really have been looking at
before and after micro needling we've
got to do microwave really yeah I think
we do I want to do it so bad yeah one
thing I will say though that I do relate
to this conversation is that when I was
pregnant uh two years ago for eight
weeks
um I that's when I like took that
inventory of like what have I done with
my life what have I not done yeah and
that's like when that hit me and it
really was though in more context of
like
accomplishments and like dreams pursued
like so
that's that yeah it gets real but I
think that's exactly it like whether
it's a pregnancy or an engagement or a
death like it really you got engaged
kind of young I think so maybe that's
why the pregnancy was the time when you
started thinking those things maybe yeah
yeah right because it was like you could
still be engaged and then
be a Broadway star yeah you know I love
how you know that's the thing that I was
upset about because you went to I know
all about your little New York
becoming alive in New York so funny I
literally am like so sad lately I'm so
sad I'm not a Broadway star I just can't
you didn't watch Felicity I loved
football
Ben
right thank you are you kidding oh my
God Scott Speedman is like driving me I
die I die around him you never watch
Felicity no why is this coming up in
context of Broadway because I moved to
New York because I watched a little girl
live her dreams in a show
she like went to NYU and she oh my
god and here's the thing he
looks like my neighbor who was like my
first crush
and yeah and no no was kind of nerdier
and he was nothing he was nothing
compared to Ben he was a loser Ben was
everything and Ben was all distant
didn't know if he liked her
he was my neighbor he looks exactly like
him this is unrelated but sort of
related Carrie Russell the first time I
ever saw her was in a Bon Jovi
um music video that really
um had me transfixed as a nine-year-old
I will say that Hollywood though too has
the same thing so you came to Hollywood
with like pursuing the dream too it's
the same thing New York and and L.A is
like it's the same Vibe I think the
other day I was saying to Dave like I
should have moved to New York and like
pursued my real dreams and he's like
don't you think it kind of was probably
for the best that you moved to LA you
could have just like a wind could have
blown you but have just fallen in front
of the train I feel like that was his
way of saying like
have you can you weren't gonna make it
on Broadway
or at least once you said that I was
like he's probably right yeah no you'll
anything doesn't he kind of look like
him how are we on doesn't he look like
him
five minutes yeah let me a little bit
look like him yeah
oh he's cute yeah have you all ever
grieved a dream
all day my whole life is grieving
like lovers and love stories that take
place in my dream land I've had my heart
broken so many times like I can't shake
off
most of my dreams well last night's
dream it was really weird I dreamed I
had a tiny puppy that would cool off in
my fish tank and just jump into the fish
you just jump in the fish tank and kind
of like wash off and then hop off but he
was friends with a fish I don't know I
don't know I woke up and I wrote it down
I'm like what a great dream but a lot of
times like I've fallen in love with an
unnamed like this person this random
person in my dream so freaking hard
that's everywhere
you're not what I made up and then I
wake up and this person's not real and
it takes me like a whole week to shake
off
well kalila I'm sad to say this after
you I literally wake up every morning
like my life is better than my dreams oh
not to say it afterwards I just had one
wow you don't have that
no I well grieving a dream like a dream
that you wish to pursue like oh that
kind of dreams
open for interpretation
I do feel
this panic in me that's like I'm 35 and
like I'm can't really be a professional
dancer wait for you to turn 40. turning
40 it's like I am desperate for all you
to turn forward I'm like oh 35
is hard but for a dancer
go on Tick Tock what are you
talking about you are a professional
dancer thank you that's the nicest thing
you've ever had like well you were gonna
go what you wanted the eating disorder
and the up toes like what is what
part are you missing the bun I just like
want to be in a Broadway chorus like you
can be in on Broadway thank you for
saying that it could be SpongeBob too
you could be banging Ariana Grande right
now
I and then in terms of like a dream that
you when you're sleeping I mean my
recurring dream that it's the last day
of high school like
it just kills me I like there's
something about that where I'm like
every time I wake up I'm like no I want
to go like I want to do it I want to go
back oh my God I'm like in a cop car
yeah like last night at school I was
like I'm out of here coffee
coffee gosh what a different experience
we had like I couldn't wait to get the
out of it oh my God high school so
rough worst time full for me that no it
is it's it is very different but I I do
remember like being excited for it to be
over because you're like whoa there's a
lot now I'm uh for real like what was
your graduation song was it the vitamin
c song
I don't know I don't remember was it
Green Day graduation
I was like I hate I was there my
graduation I fought the law and the law
was it no there's a graduation song and
they were like please leave you just
took us to court please leave ma'am but
I do think we graduated at Northwestern
on the campus there and there it which
is like near a really good hot dog place
so that's what I was thinking about that
day was hot dogs yeah sorry you're not
from Chicago okay like Santa bad a
Chicago dog we stitched I think what was
really sweet was for me after graduation
the most impactful person in my life
outside of my stepdad and my English
teacher who would like drop me off
because I was really struggling with my
mental health like my senior year and my
junior year and I kept being um locked
up in a psych Hospital
and so what they were like
these amazing people were like okay we
know she's smart she came here from the
Philippines she once had she was
maintaining 4.0 and then she just kind
of fell off she's going through a crisis
let's just help her out so my um who's
now my stepdad my history teacher would
um drop me off after school straight
home my English teacher would pick me up
to take me to school
and they worked very closely with the
school therapist who showed up at my
graduation with his wife and he gave me
this like it was super emotional because
I was never I was probably never going
to see him again because he was like the
school counselor so sweet yeah
he gave me this little like Sketchbook
because he knew like I like to write
books yeah
um but high school was so rough but I
gotta say like adults towards the end
like really showed up for me and
um I I get emotional thinking about it
because I'm like oh like
um I don't know it's just sometimes they
do you know there are great teachers out
there who are gonna go outside of like
the norm of like that's probably
inappropriate to like pick a high school
girl up and take her to school but
they're like no she's struggling
she's not gonna graduate if we don't
help her yeah that makes me so happy for
you yeah and he's my stepdad now Raj
that is so cute oh my God amazing yeah
um we have to wrap it wait before we do
I have a such an important question I've
been dying to ask you Annie
why am I so pretty
have you had and do you know about and
can you tell us about Philly ice water
ice cream
Water Ice Water Ice yeah it's like
Italian ice what is it water is we don't
how do you say it it's water ice I say
water what is it
it's like an icy like a Italian ice but
it's like soft it's really good yeah
Rita's
we don't is it like snow cones
it's something that I've never seen it
is tomorrow I'll bring you read us
tomorrow it's like special but in pla is
it
you can get the best it's called happy
ice that's what I've been looking at on
Tick Tock it looks insane it's so good
yeah I know it's a mess this was like
our whole life like we just had this
every day yeah we don't know about this
but we had we would go to this place
called transili's on the way to my
Quaker School and it we would get water
ice and
um there's like a million different
flavors and we would get
um cheese pretzels it was just soft
pretzels and they would put them in a
toaster which is literally the best food
I've ever had in my life like number one
but I'll bring you guys water ice next
week okay I'll bring you one yes and
I'll I'll just get I'll get Rita's for
you but I will say this okay I will say
this about the dream thing I do not ever
this is my greatest life I could ever
imagine I'm so happy with it I can't
imagine doing anything else I'm so
the fact that I had a dream to be a
comedian and that I figured it out and I
do it professionally is like
unbelievable and I'm excited to see how
how much more I can do with it but
sometimes I let my brain go to what if I
had just like married my Santa Fe
boyfriend lived a regular life had kids
lived in Santa Fe grew my mustache out
was like a yoga teacher and it never
feels better it never in the dream feels
better
the way I see it is like ever
would be maybe easier but because you
know Bobby used to always say no this is
fate this is fate and I don't believe in
fate I don't believe in destiny that is
very confining to me the thought of it
but I think about like
any which way that my life
could have gone would have been okay
like if I had ended up living in Europe
or if my dad hadn't died whatever which
way or if I met a completely different
set of people if I never did this it
would have been okay and just as
important and just as great and just as
worth living for I feel like every
sliding doors movie is like that's the
end of it is right like it would have
been good it's fine yeah yeah whichever
way is fine you wouldn't have known any
other way anyways you know but this is
the best life but this is a pretty cool
traveling and doing comedy and having
podcasts rules all right I think
um we have to wrap it up yeah
Esther final thoughts final thoughts are
I love our new tank tops so cute and
hopefully there's a link below telling
you what to do not just wait
because we're just little handmaids and
we don't know how to do anything we need
you Commander
um thank you guys so much for being here
with us today we love you we love each
other and we will see you next week with
a brand new episode love one another I
am Julie Chan mundes
bye guys
[Music]
um